they should be [ __ ] put to death for
what they did
there you go there's a hot take
people's criticism recently have used
that you've mellow yeah Bill be the way
you used to be and go around hurt people
there's no come up to you say hey man I
was going through a really bad period in
my life in your comedy helped me and
it's weird you almost feel like uh
embarrassed when they say it because
it's just like
oh because I'm doing this for me but
you've always gone back to stand up
right why is it
because I love it and it was just like
total like culture shock like I had
never been in a rumor I was just like
the only white guy and there's like 300
you know black people and I was just
like you know at first you go super
liberal where you're just like oh wow
everybody here is cool and then
start to go individually like oh this
guy's like my white friend Mark who's a
piece of [ __ ] yeah well like it annoys
me when I watched the news and you just
see these weather men go I'll tell you
it's gonna be a hot one what are we
doing right now
what is today today is Tuesday yeah yeah
oh we got jackets on and we're tired
this isn't a [ __ ] real job
foreign
ometry on the road from the USA I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People it's our last interview of the
trip and we are finishing with a bang
it's literally our favorite comedian
alive today Bilbo welcome to
trigonometry how are you it's great to
have you on man what a pleasure I forgot
that was the name of the podcast that
brings back some bad memories like what
just being bad at math
Algebra 2 and trig is how far I go yeah
yeah well listen man welcome welcome to
the show I mentioned that we've been
traveling around uh and it's been a wild
ride for us we've talked to all sorts of
people and America is an amazing place
but also very very like divided place a
lot of people are angry now why do you
think that is like how has America got
to this point because people are getting
their information on the internet so
they think that a lot of people you know
if you go in the the internet everybody
seems like they're angry but if you go
outside and walk around the knot it's
like to just walk around screaming at
each other there's the I think the
Internet is just like an abusive
relationship and everybody just you just
get to say whatever you want sort of
especially if you're not in the public
eye and you just have some Anonymous
name and no photo you just get to just
be like the biggest [ __ ] ever either
for sport or you actually mean it so you
know
I think it would appear a lot less angry
if
um
you know people weren't allowed to
comment and communicate with each other
on the internet you know or that you
actually had to say who you were and
where you lived I think people would be
a little more courteous to one another
but um bilba approves of doxing down to
the headline yeah I mean there's that
and then there's the whole history of
this country you know right coming to a
head maybe or just resurfacing I don't
know
and does it worry you Bill that people
are more divided than ever that we've
got this kind of Left Right divide and
the left looks at the right and the
right looks at the left and no one seems
to really trust each other anymore
uh no I just don't think any of that's
real it's not real it's just like and
the people from England and around you
guys always ask these questions like
what's it like everybody yelling at each
other and walking around with a machine
gun and it's just like it's like you
know what I mean I'm trying to think of
The Stereotype of where you guys come
from it's just it's just not this it's
it's
kind of you you are what they show and
what what everybody shows now is
heightened emotions because there's so
many places to look at things like crazy
gets people to stop and watch but like
actual you know people just chilling out
no one wants to see that they want to
see like fighting and that type of thing
so
um I know what you're saying but we've
been talking to people hey you've been
here for a week you got it down man
please by all means tell me about my
country
I'm just asking the question bill yeah
that's cool I answered it you think
you're still going back yeah but
according you know I know you guys are
gonna go back to England oh they're
[ __ ] fat everybody's got a gun in the
visor of their car I know what you guys
are going to do you know actually
Americans are not that fat it's the fat
Americans who are extra fat most
Americans are the same as the British
well our food supply is poison yeah it
was taken over by one group of people
and they own the rights to the seeds and
all of that type of stuff and they
forced out all of these Farmers if their
seeds blew under their property they
could sue them for using their seeds and
the media just ignored all of that
because they get paid by them that's
sort of what is going on globally is
everybody's is just choosing money the
bag is [ __ ] kids say nowadays
um that's what the problem is nobody is
uh you know they're everybody's
screaming and yelling about [ __ ] that
doesn't matter like stand-up comedians
they'll yell about that but they won't
talk about literally people uh poisoning
their own countrymen I mean they should
be [ __ ] put to death for what they
did
there you go there's a hot take I mean I
know if I did it if I did it if I
[ __ ] went to one donut shop and put
something in a [ __ ] donut
that hurts somebody or caused them to
have some sort of medical episode that
would be a I would not be sitting here
right now but they somehow you know you
know how it is Catholic Church can do
what they do
kind of move people around and uh
everything's all right as long as you
[ __ ] you know you're paying people
it's good so
that's what it is
it's a great Point why is it do you
think that we get more obsessed by the
stuff that doesn't matter your pronouns
blah blah blah then the actually really
important stuff like the fact there's a
fentanyl crisis in this country because
you're being steered away from it
there's also money and and it's just
like you have to sacrifice
someone in on one of those big news
channels would have to sacrifice their
cushy life
and uh
you know and fall on the knife and
nothing would happen I mean that's what
you probably Learned was Snowden what he
did you know and like he did that for
all of us he should be treated like a
hero half the people you know over here
the big thing is if you know somebody's
fighting for the people uh they're
immediately branded a socialist or a
communist
and they somehow try to tie him to uh
Putin it's just like Ori just thinks the
banking system's a little [ __ ] up and
maybe uh it shouldn't be run by a
private Corporation could be that
um yeah
that you're being asked so much about
politics
there's a stand-up
uh no because I I just think that uh
you know they don't want real answers
they want idiots like me talking about
it and then everyone just go that's just
some idiot comedian that does [ __ ] jokes
but they don't want like uh I don't know
I don't think they even answer the
questions or even ask them anymore I
don't know it's getting depressing
I don't know that's what this is why I
just sort of tapped off because I was in
it all like conspiracy theory as far as
like you know not saying the moon was
made out of cheese but I got into that
whole Federal Reserve thing and
everything and I just all I did was just
meet other crazy people and we weren't
getting anything done
and uh we just agreeing with each other
and I just after a while it just became
uh you know depressing so I just sort of
just
I was you know uh you know I kind of
have an issue with the higher power
though right now
what's your issue with the higher power
he's lazy
he makes a lot of [ __ ] up people and
takes no responsibility and blames it on
the devil that whole [ __ ] thing is
just [ __ ] up to me and uh the joke
I've been doing in my ACT is that I I
believe in a God but not that one that
cares I think he just sort of made even
if you just look like the animal kingdom
like what
so like rabbits are just here to be
eaten yeah and they die horrible [ __ ]
deaths there's really no point they
they're designed to like just [ __ ] all
the time and make more so everything you
know they can be eaten alive
were you say he's God's an absent father
uh
he's like you know [ __ ] artist studio
I just made this and then he makes that
and just [ __ ] he's like
yeah I just picture him in some [ __ ]
giant Loft
creating and then moving on to the next
thing I don't think he's coming back or
anybody else I think we're just gonna
ride this out and then one day the light
goes out it just goes quiet and then
something else Springs up and that's the
next thing he works on
um and you think that's just going to be
the way it rolls yeah that makes sense
why do you pick the subjects that you
pick when you do comedy why are you
attracted to these subjects because
there's a lot of comedians who would
love to do the stuff that you do but
they're too scared like they're too
scared they're just doing what they want
to do and there's also like you know
we'll stand up and see you've got to
figure out
you know am I am I this person am I that
person do I want to talk about this and
you know
um
look as much as I talk about what I talk
about I don't like I don't choose
political sides like I've seen some
comedians do I would never
um
I wouldn't do that because I just I just
feel like you know I I know I don't have
the answers so I'm not going to sit
there and tell people like uh
you know who they're gonna vote who they
should vote for or whatever not saying a
bunch of comics do that but I've seen
people kind of doing that especially
during the uh
the last two that we've had in the last
two elections that we had it got pretty
wild
the options it was slim pickings
yeah so now we're with this guy and just
I don't know I just miss old school
politicians
you know it just sort of gave you a
speech gave you some hope as opposed to
like you know now I don't know what we
have there's literally actors out here
talking how they want to run for
president
it strikes me as hilarious it's like you
got this great [ __ ] life you're
making 10 20 million a movie and you
want to get a job where you're going to
have like dead babies on your [ __ ]
conscience because the bombs don't
always land on the bad guys and you're
gonna age like 40 years and eight you're
like what the [ __ ] would you ever want
that job for is beyond me
you know maybe they just think that
they're so good at acting that they can
just play any role do you know what I
mean like the present is just another
role to play
I think they're staying ahead of their
depression
so they just need another challenge so
they don't sit and they're not alone
with their thoughts
I'm pretty [ __ ] up
what am I doing next I'll run for
president
[Laughter]
I'll never sit in traffic again that
that'll shut this off yeah
um yeah but but
serious but Bill you do go to like the
more contentious topics you do kind of
say it there but they do interest me
everybody does
you're telling me is there anything that
I'm talking about you don't talk about
you might not talk about the way I do
but yeah but a lot of people wouldn't
talk about it because those are
comedians we know a ton of comedians who
wouldn't even go near the subjects yeah
yeah but I know a ton that do sure of
course yeah yeah I mean it's just all
like you know it's like music I'm
playing this style of music you're
playing that and it's like there's
everything from you know that stuff I
was just playing you that I like to
meditate to yeah all the way to like you
know my sugar
so you know it's a uh
there's no right or wrong way to do
stand-up comedy you just do it the way
you want to do it and you listen to your
voice and if this is what you want to
talk about you talk about it but you
don't give into pressure like hey man
you're up there you're not saying
anything it's just like maybe I don't
want to yeah
maybe I don't want to maybe that's how I
deal with [ __ ]
the depression of of paying attention is
I go up there and give people a [ __ ]
mental break you know like maybe that's
what those style of people do and I got
I gotta be honest with you I I love
Comics like that
yeah and I I like you know somebody
that's doing something completely
different than I am it's easy to follow
because they're not stepping on anything
that I'm talking about and I love silly
you know I love absurd I love
observational comedy prop acts guitar
acts as long as you make me laugh yeah I
I I I love it
and do you sometimes feel like people
paint this image of you like he's just
this angry guy who you know who doesn't
like women because they watch the ACT
which I think is nonsense by the way
whereas well it's kind of true in the
beginning
[Laughter]
I had you know I had a lot of issues
with women I still have a lot uh I still
go back to some you know tried and true
ones and uh it is funny whenever I start
to write a new hour it's just I always
it's always that and I and I was saying
the other night I was saying ladies just
don't worry I'm gonna iron this out
before the special it's just I always
like
and I don't be honest with you I don't
know where
most of that uh I know where some of it
comes from I don't know where most of
that came from but um
um but I I it really had nothing to do
with women I don't think
but like being in a relationship brought
me back to like you know
like a suffocating oppressive sort of
thing and it just sort of felt like you
know
which it wasn't never the woman's fault
in the relationship I was in it was just
that I was not in touch with my emotions
so I didn't know what I've really truly
felt so I was always yeah it just you
know
I you know for a while every time I was
in a relationship I felt like I was in
this little rubber raft heading towards
the waterfall
uh which is not the place you want to be
in uh in a relationship so
um
unfortunately I met my wife so
because when you're on staff hurting
people
because when you when you're on stage
you it looks like a guy who is looking
at the world and struggling to
understand everything that's happening
and sort of railing against it which I
think a lot of people particularly guys
can and women can connect with you know
I I guess so I don't know I don't know
I don't know I did read I did read a
book though the ones that kind of made
you know
that I would recommend to all you
English guys who always go like what's
going on over there right Everybody's
Got a Gun
[Laughter]
um I read this book called Wilmington's
lie you should read that and then
everything up until now including
abortion everything just goes it's like
oh I'm not saying it's right it just
makes like oh this is how we ended up
here
um what's it called again Wilmington's
lie I'll make sure to read that yeah
yeah I mean it's got everything in there
it's got like you know uh white
supremacy it's got elections Democrat
Republicans it's got like black and
white the whole
thing you know
it's kind of unfair to just put it on
Wilmington it's like Wilmington is like
sort of like a petri dish to show the
whole country what was uh you know
how kind of we ended up here I got so
much out of that book it was it was
you know it's actually in a weird way
even though everything is so [ __ ] up
still but it's at least you understand
like well it kind of makes sense where
this [ __ ] up if this is what we're
standing on type of thing
uh bill it's it's interesting thing you
talk about meeting your wife and what a
positive difference made in your life
and it shows you how messed up sometimes
the way we look at comedy is because
people people's criticism sometimes
recently have used that you've mellowed
which like in a normal world like that's
like a good thing right but for a
comedian people will say that meaning
you've you've lost an edge have you
mellowed yeah it has oh yeah I'm not as
mad as as I used to be and like
uh yeah they are right I have and they
they want me to just be angry my whole
life and not enjoy living
is because they're angry and that
they're not enjoying their lives so with
them I don't take it personally I just
hope that they can somehow I don't know
find some sort of Peace because it's no
way to go because you're just going
around like you know yeah Bill be the
way you used to be and go around hurt
people
you [ __ ] wild outbursts or whatever
and it's like and then there's also you
know there's um
there's there's all kinds of different
people that come at me with that [ __ ]
and and it's could be based in just like
uh where they're at in their
relationships with women or they're like
you know racists and [ __ ] and they you
know
like to say things about me and my life
and stuff but I mean that's just where
they are and I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah I don't I don't anybody who like uh
you know whenever I put something out I
just I read until the first negative
comment and then I do the math all right
that was like 12 good ones and one bad
one it's pretty good all right that's it
and then I just I don't look at it and I
uh
you know get off my life yeah well this
is what Joe was saying to us is like man
just stop reading the comments just
don't read the comments and I never used
to understand it because I was like yeah
but you've got to be able to hear you
know the different sides and then I
realized it's the internet it you know
yeah and then like what I always noticed
when I was uh coming up you know when I
was selling my CDs or DVDs after the
show was that all the cool people you
wanted to talk to and hang out with were
like I don't want to bug you and they
would leave and all the idiots just
annoying people wanted to sit there and
talk your ear off and like that's what
the internet is all of those people not
all but most of the people commenting uh
those people and the people you really
want to talk to are not reaching out to
you or or whatever they're just like
like they'll just watch and be like I
really enjoyed that we should go see him
when he comes to town or I wasn't into
that you know let's watch something else
and
somebody some of them are funny though
I saw one
this person wrote and this is why I can
never like Bill Burr and they showed
this clip and what I loved was there was
no tweet above it saying and why don't
you like Bill Burr and it's just like
and this is why like the whole world was
waiting like ah finally this person
answered why they don't like this stupid
[ __ ] comedian and the behavior on
social media you know they're always
coming at people in the public eye
saying uh you know these celebrities are
this and that the [ __ ] behavior of
the average person like they're wound up
in it too they're living their own
little TV and this is why and
everybody's supposed to be like oh my
God that's so [ __ ] profound
um it was commenting on because when I I
did Conan right like the day after Trump
got elected and it was like a [ __ ]
funeral out here in L.A and I gotta go
on this I'm like yeah it's not going to
be that bad you know I know what's gonna
happen or whatever you know just trying
to put his positive spin on it and they
were saying that's the reason why that
they don't they don't like me and it's
just like um I got a buddy of mine Joe
bartnick he says you know everybody acts
like Trump is the worst president ever
he's like he's not he's not he's like
George W bush he goes we had a 20
trillion dollar Surplus and this guy
started two non-ending Wars and gave all
the money to his friends and bankrupted
us you know that's [ __ ] Wayward but
they all do their [ __ ] Obama drone
bombing weddings Clinton was the guy who
did that [ __ ] with the bank that made
some jerk off you know working at a
subway qualified to get a loan for a 400
000 house which created that whole thing
in 2008. you just keep going back I
think that you don't like
the only like uh
like truly like good person like human
being I feel that's been present in my
lifetime is Jimmy Carter and you see the
guys in his 90s he's still you know
building houses for the homeless he's
out there swinging a hammer like
everybody else just goes off and buys
land that sits on an aquifer because
they're like you know like I guess
betting on global warming is that what
you do as a world leader
um and this guy's actually out there
trying to help people and um it's funny
I remember when I was a kid he was
considered weak
um that was the thing
um
because he didn't you know start a war
with Iran I remember that because of the
hostage thing and he was able to you
know
I don't know I don't know I just see
like he was we should have kept that guy
forever well I mean I don't know who
knows maybe if he was in too long he'd
start to be a lunatic but like that guy
just seems like you know
Bill coming back to what you said about
going on Conan on the day after Trump
gets elected one of the things I always
liked about your comedies you always try
and take the opposite side to whatever
not always but often you take the
opposite side to whatever the mainstream
thing is because that's your instinct as
a comic like where'd you get that from
uh pushing people away
oh well no I expected my know-how my I
understand myself now no that's what
that's all that was was pushing people
away because then if I'm alone no one
can hurt me so that literally that it
just filters into your comedy and then
you're a bit of a contrarian you know
you're just like it's like no it's just
like look anybody who's a comedian a
really funny one had something really
[ __ ] up happen to him or a bunch of
[ __ ] up things happened to him so it's
like you're sort of uh
you know I guess reactive I don't know
what it is but you you uh it filters
into what you do
so
um
it's not like a conscious Choice as much
as it became a really a defense thing
and then when you get on a comedy stage
it becomes actually not what you wanted
but you're just ingrained in that like
I'm gonna say what you don't want me to
say
and and I'm doing it because offstage me
does that and then people just sort of
[ __ ] off and leave you alone and then
when you're on stage they're not leaving
and then they start heckling you it's
like oh this isn't what I wanted I
wanted them to like me so
um yeah there is there's all of that
[ __ ] there's a lot of that
hey Francis are you looking for Creative
Solutions to protect your most important
asset are we advertising condoms
sometimes I have no idea what's about to
come out of your mouth I just know it's
never good what's your most important
asset my brain
that's a depressing thought as we all
know for people who own their own
business their most important asset is
their business which is why you need the
right people in your corner to protect
your business rapid GRC or one of
Europe's leading sap security governance
risk and compliance management
Specialists sap is one of the world's
leading producers of Erp software for
the management of business processes
developing solutions that facilitate
effective data processing and infant for
information
and information flow across
organizations rapid GRC are at the
Forefront of securing this data for
organizations I have no idea what any of
these words mean I just hope I've got
them in the right order
one two three breathe rapid GRC are a
small but perfectly formed company who
respond quickly to client requirements
they have a highly experienced project
task force who can design build test and
audit sap user access management from
the ground up and deliver within budget
I almost got some of that rapid GRC have
a fast turnaround and a dedicated team
of Specialists that can be on hand 24 7
to handle client requirements check out
the sap Services they offer on their
website
www.rapidhyphengrc.com or email info at
rapid
hyphengrc.com for further details and
quote rapid25 to get a 25 discount for
trigonometry fans that's
www.rapid hyphengrc.com or email info at
rapid hyphengrc.com for further details
and quote rapid 25 to get 25 off for new
trigonometry fans
you talk a lot about masculinity in your
current special why is it that you talk
about it so much now was it because I
never talked about masculinity I talked
about myself okay right and then you're
rebranding it as masculine masculinity
okay I'm just glad you didn't say toxic
but you know I the reason I guess why I
spoke about masculinity is because it's
a lot of a lot of things that men
connect with you know that feeling you
know of anger you know the the
relationship with the father not being
able to process that having kids being a
dad and going oh I don't want to pass
this stuff on to my kid right I'm sure
my dad thought that I think I mean my
kids will will think that there's always
stuff that you're gonna like
you know you're gonna make mistakes
um I just think the big thing is
apologizing to them and addressing in
the moment that you did it that you
messed up and that you're really sorry
and then I go back to it two or three
times
um
I did that I messed up the other day
with my daughter and then uh
I was saying I can't believe I did that
I really the third time I apologize I I
was like it makes me sad that I did that
and she was like I don't want you to be
sad well I was just like all right it's
good now we're good now yeah it was
really cute I became a dad a few months
ago so I haven't got to that stage yet
how has that changed you the experience
of being becoming a father and being a
father
um oh God I actually the thing I learned
is like you know you think you know you
buy some
huge house and they have all the toys
and then you're gonna have like this
you're gonna raise a good empathetic
person it's not how it works it's like
you can give them everything in the
world the one the biggest thing that
they need is your time
so if you're busy like everybody in this
businesses
um you have to say no to stuff and you
have to like you know like my big thing
was I went on you know everything has an
app now like my daughter's school has an
app so I just looked up when's your fall
break when's the Christmas break when's
February when's April and I just sent
that to everybody I'm not working these
weeks so
um
you know uh
yeah she said some like heartbreaking
[ __ ] to me like kids just kids really
get to like you know I shot a movie
earlier this year and she's like Dad can
you you know can you hang out with me
today and I was like ah you know I go I
gotta work today she's like oh and I
said no I go I'm on I got two more days
left in this movie
and she goes uh
she goes I don't like when you do movies
I was like I don't like it I go I don't
like it either and then she goes I go
but I'm done in two days and she goes
good then he can play with me forever
and you just walk out like I am the
worst parent but it's just like this is
how I [ __ ]
pay for our life so I have to go do this
[ __ ] so
um
like those things you have to let those
things land and sit in the pain of them
and be like all right I need to make
sure I do and it's like I'm gonna have
to go to work
so I just have to make sure I don't work
I gotta have that balance of
you know keeping the lights on and then
like like being there but like I am
there a lot though that is the great
thing about this job is like I kind of
work when I want to work
um it's just once every two weeks I go
away for three days you know on you know
some sort of gig or whatever but I don't
do anything longer than like three three
four days I was gonna ask you you know
front neither Francis or I grew up with
a lot of money so we have like a lot of
drive you know that's how I feel about
it and I the one thing that I always
talk about with kids is like not raising
them to be spoiled brats when they've
got you know this or whatever they've
got do you do you worry about that
uh yeah a little bit but like
um
it's not
you know
we just like laugh a lot and we're
always joking around and we're just like
uh you know both my kids my wife's
hilarious and there's just a lot of
joking around and laughing and things
aren't really like serious
so I think if you sort of
uh raise them
you don't hold them accountable and then
also if you're if you're into like the
status of having money and we need to
join this country club and you should
hang out with their kids and marry into
that family and do that that [ __ ] you
know I think maybe that that I don't
know this is my first time doing this so
I have no idea I think you know but my
kids are really uh they're amazing
they're really funny they're very happy
and they know they're loved and they're
very secure and um
you know it's fun it's just you know
whatever they get into you just said all
right you know you kind of nudge them
that see how long it's
tracks but um you know it's a hard thing
if they're getting into something that
you're into and then they send it not
into it anymore you gotta be like
dude you're gonna be a drummer yeah do
you not worry that they're going to want
to go into show business and you having
seen like the way show business is and
no show business is awesome
like none of us have a real job what are
we doing right now
what is today today's Tuesday yeah yeah
oh we got jackets on and we're talking
about this isn't a [ __ ] real job
so like the job that I had I I yeah when
I had like a day job I [ __ ] I hated
going to work yeah I had a blast coming
over here I was listening to my music
yeah you know listen to Bill doing my
little French lessons and [ __ ] in the
car that's what I do in the car and I
you know come over here
you know it's just like this business is
a is a great business it's you just have
to there is a part of it though when
when you start getting to be like
there's a certain level of success that
you hit that you really have to watch
out that they don't burn you out because
it just becomes like oh then all of a
sudden you know nobody was calling you
and then too many people are calling you
and you're just you know how you make it
is like you know hey will you drive
sitting in the middle of nowhere to do
this [ __ ] yes yes
so you got to get out of that mindset
yeah and kind of be like all right yeah
especially when you have like when I
have like kids and stuff so
um I shot a movie that I I wrote with a
buddy of mine Ben tischel from Miramax
and um
ended up getting talked into directing
it too and simply because we were coming
out of covid for the 90th millionth time
and projects were starting to go again
and just everyone all the directors were
taken up everyone was like you know no
one was free everybody had a project
that they said that they were going to
do over the last year and a half or
whatever
so and then it was just like all right
if we don't get a director soon it's
going to go away and they just kept
coming back going you want to do it I
was like and then I finally just went
all right I'll do it and I'm so happy I
did it even though it was it was a ton
of work and everything but um
like but after this movie like I'm not
I'm just doing stand-up for the rest of
the year so when I'll finish this movie
sometime like September or October it'll
be delivered and all of that and then
um like I'm just not doing [ __ ] I'm
watching football I'm hanging out with
my kids I'm not doing
you know I got my stand up dates but
that's not work that's just fun yeah
a lot of people will look at you and
widely regard you is probably one of the
best comics of your generation right and
whether you accept that or not that's
how a lot of people accept it I resent
you soon
the both of us would suddenly yeah how
do you get to be that good at something
what do you sacrifice do you see what I
mean like to to get to that level
uh you don't really sacrifice anything
you just sort of I becomes
I just think it becomes a game within
yourself
where you and when you as a young comic
and just like a young person you know
all of a sudden you're out in the world
yeah what's everybody doing oh they're
wearing that jacket I gotta wear that
jacket it's very you're looking like
that and then you know then you
gradually start to figure out well you
know I did that I'm doing what other
people are doing
and I'm not getting anywhere and I'm not
happy
so then hopefully you get to a point of
like all right well if I'm not going to
make it I'm at least not going to make
it saying what I want to say
and then you go down that road and then
down that road it becomes
you know I keep doing this thing or I
know I can do that and I'm not able to
do it on stage and you just work on your
game like the way an athlete would like
if you can't go to your left start going
to your left
yeah you know and um so what was that
moment for you when you you were like
well [ __ ] it if I'm if I'm not going to
get anywhere at least I'll I'll do it my
way what happened like was there a
moment like that was it gradual it was
1999
and uh
see I come out here I'd gotten uh an
acting gig
made a little bit of money and then it
went away I basically went from nobody
got an acting gig on a show and then we
got canceled all in like six months it
was like boom and then slammed back down
to the ground
and then not getting spots and then my
whole
um
Focus got shifted because people were
looking me as a guy who used to be on a
TV show or at least I thought they were
they probably didn't give a [ __ ] but in
my head everybody cared I was like that
tweet and this is why everyone you know
this is why I don't like bill so I I was
in that mindset so uh yeah somewhere
around 99 I was just like
uh
this is a brutal place to live when you
have nothing going on La is [ __ ]
brutal
um so I was just sitting there and I
thought
all right why the [ __ ] did I get in this
business I got in this business because
I wanted to be a comedian I wanted to be
a great comedian I want to be a comedian
that other comedians respected and said
nice things about
I never had a desire to do any of this
acting [ __ ] this just [ __ ]
happened because I went on an audition
because that's what people in New York
and out here we're doing with comedians
oh have you want to read for this
sitcom order so then I moved back
I just said [ __ ] this I'm going back to
New York and there was things that I
wanted to do there was a show
um at the old Boston comedy club on
Sunday night uh it was the the Uptown
show which was the black show right all
the black Comics or whatever it was run
by uh will sylvence and uh Jamestown
Harrison I always wanted to do that room
not that room like I always wanted to go
in front of a crowd like that because I
grew up and he's all these albums one of
the albums I listened to was was all the
Richard Pryor ones and his albums were
so live sounding that you could just you
know
not only like the characters he did I
have a picture of what they look like
the people in the crowd that certain
louder laughs I know what everybody
looks like and
um
I just uh I don't know why I just
because I was listening to them so much
that was what a crowd looked like that
was kind of weird some white kid in the
middle of the suburbs so then I came
down to New York one time
with the late great Patrice O'Neill and
New York was already freaking out about
this guy Patrice O'Neal from Boston so I
tagged along like his [ __ ] chauffeur
and they brought us down uh he went over
to uh Sunday night at the Boston
and I just remember going in there
and it was just like total like culture
shock like I had never been in a room
where I was just like the only white guy
and there's like 300 you know black
people and I was just like
it was amazing and also I was like
scared and all this type of [ __ ] and uh
I remember I saw Chris Tucker went up
right before Fridays came out I was like
I don't know who the [ __ ] that is but
that guy
is amazing he's you know and
and I remember thinking like just
knowing I was like I know I can do this
room I just can't do it now because I'm
scared so I had to like
you know and that was like 95 it wasn't
until 99 then I moved back and I said
[ __ ] this
I'm just gonna go down and do and I
started doing those shows
I also started doing those shows because
other Comics Black Comics would be like
saying that the people in that room were
funnier
and those rooms are harder I was you
know it's [ __ ] annoying me
you know it's like you you're like hey
we won the championship and they're like
oh there's a team down the street that
could kick your ass but they're not
allowed to leave it's like ah [ __ ] I
gotta go play them now so I went over
there and uh and I just learned so much
about comedy
and uh you know there's an easy way to
do that room you go up there and you're
like you just play the fish out of the
water like oh gee I'm the only white guy
here and oh boy am I nervous that's
always going to get a laugh or you can
actually go up there and talk about what
you want to talk about and that was
something that I learned how to you know
I was learning how to do that in in the
mainstream rooms and then I learned how
to do it there and then also by going to
all of those rooms
uh the good thing that happened to me as
a person was it wasn't I didn't just see
like uh you know this is a crowd full of
black people you know when I first was
there that's what I saw and everybody I
talked to that's all I
saw because it was like just so
different from it it became like you
start to see individuals and then you
start to see uh you know at first you go
super liberal where you're just like oh
wow everybody here is cool and
once you start to go individually like
oh this guy's like my white friend Mark
who's a piece of [ __ ] oh this person's
like my friend Doug who's a great guy
you know so it's just like the then you
know I feel like uh
that's a huge thing
um
a huge experience that as a comedian
that you get that other people don't
um I remember when I did stand up in uh
India one time I did a Mumbai India and
afterwards
I hung out with all of these comics
from the local scene and we were sitting
there in this restaurant my wife got
this great picture I was sitting there
and they were asking all these these
questions about stand-up it was the
exact same questions that people ask
here
and it was all sort of like you know how
do you write your stuff how long did it
take you to start blah blah blah and
then finally one of them just goes uh
all right who's the comic out there
that's selling just a whole bunch of
tickets and you have no idea why
I was just like wow that's that [ __ ]
exists
over here and you just see like the you
know the humanity
where it's just like yeah over here you
got the ex it's the exact same
people it's just you know
things are different the clothes are
different the language is different
people look different the food's
different and all that but like the
basic
thing you know there's good people
there's you know people finagling you
know and it's just kind of like so I
from Sunday night to Boston I learned
Now everywhere I go you know uh
to try to see the individual and then
try to make the connection to the person
I know here
to to kind of gain like a good person
bad person or or like what's this person
up to is this just cool we talking
comedy is this person you know what's
going on here so um
yeah uh
it was all during that time of Discovery
was so I was making all these Leaps and
Bounds as a comedian but zero as a
person
because I felt like I think a lot of
comics it's just like
you know I'm broken and I'm hurt and I'm
gonna go on stage and I'm gonna do this
and people are going to laugh and
they're going to love me and then I'm
going to feel good and everything's
gonna be fine and then one day you just
realize I gotta turn around and face all
of this [ __ ] the same way anybody who
doesn't do this job has to
and uh yeah that's a fun 15 years
I feel like you mentioned Patrice
he's one of the greats what was she like
as a person to be around
um
foreign
he was everything everything was on tent
everything was that guy was on 10. if he
was being cool he was the coolest guy he
ever met if he was being funny he was
the funniest guy you ever met he was
being an [ __ ] he wanted to [ __ ]
kill him I still have arguments with him
like that's how like the level of this
guy he's been dead for like [ __ ]
11 coming up in 11 years I can't believe
it but like this [ __ ] I'm still figuring
out that he crossed the line and up
there because I was so like
you know slow I wasn't up to what he was
doing but
um
you know I had all kinds of uh you know
amazing conversations and just talking
about life how we ended up where we were
at how the two of us ended up being
friends
you know I'd Fallen outs with them I
just I had like everything I mean it was
like a [ __ ] mini-series with that guy
so there's no real way to sum him up in
a few minutes but I I will say that you
know
you know if guys like him you know Mitch
Hedberg Bernie Mac we've lost so many
like amazing people like I I often
wonder like how many tickets would I be
selling these guys are still around
you know just one of those things that's
another way to make it live
keep living
did he influence your comedy at all did
he did he ever say to oh man you need to
go like this way or that way or
he used to try to do that to me in the
beginning
which was funny which was classic him
because I'd actually be doing stand up
longer than him and he'd been
pontificating but like the thing about
him I remember him was like early on he
was challenging himself like going on
stage and opening with a different joke
and like when you're a new comic when
you first start like yeah you're a new
joke yeah your opening joke is your life
raft yeah that's all right this is going
to get me and he's you know he was kind
of doing stuff like that but um
um yeah yeah he was you know it was we
were both too [ __ ] up
kids so we had it you know
Good Times bad times had to like [ __ ]
take breaks from each other I mean we
used to take breaks from white people in
general and like I had to take breaks
from going down to The Cellar sometimes
it's like I just want to go down there
and just [ __ ]
have to have all my deflector Shields up
and be [ __ ] you know
shooting Claymores over at everybody it
was a [ __ ] War it was so stupid
it's really been glamorized that table
at the cellar but it was [ __ ] what we
did was stupid we just [ __ ] were rip
it was funny but we never did anything
creatively I don't know the way we
helped each other was actually coming
out of that it's really hard to hurt my
feelings
like I mean I can handle it like it
takes a lot
it takes a lot
uh so um
yeah but I I you know there's so many of
those comics
you know that
you know I'm still a fan of stand-up and
I just you know
Miss
besides them like
like man what would they be saying about
this you know what I mean and like
um how great would stand-up comedy be
if this like
there's like 20 of them
that were you know
better than I was that Pat just seemed
to I don't know I don't know what
happened I don't know if I just got
older and I just knew people and they
were just all dying but like so many
people just passed away that were just
you know absolute beasts and they were
like on their way to something there was
a kid I I I don't know his name because
I just discovered him
um when he passed away something and it
just was heartbreaking to see
this kid's stuff and he was like 28 the
stuff he was doing in the angle that he
had I was just like oh man he
yeah he was already great but he was he
was going to be somebody that really had
uh
something to say like he he would have
been great for stand-up
um so sucks why do you think it is that
so many Comics Die Young
[Music]
um
I don't know I wanted that sometimes is
it aren't there just a bunch of young
people dying they're just they don't
have like fans so nobody knows
I mean there's so many people out there
struggling with drugs and stuff that die
you see all these Billboards and stuff
you just
don't know their name and never saw them
play a guitar or tell you some jokes so
uh but you don't think there's the
tortured artist thing that you know
people who are creative you talked about
it the anger is what drives you or the
[ __ ] up childhood is what drives you
and a lot of those people are then
musicians are the same right do you
don't think there's an element of that
I think there is but I think it's also
glamorized and I also think that it
doesn't uh you're not incl you know just
because you have a [ __ ] up childhood
doesn't mean you don't end up becoming
an architect you know what I mean so I
think there's a lot of um
you know and then they make movies about
Comedians and they you know you have to
raise the stakes you know we got to keep
the ball moving so it's just because you
know like that's why I use that
reference earlier I guess when I was
talking about God in his Loft yeah
because my idea of painters is that
they're all crazy just just you know
cutting their [ __ ] ears off and [ __ ]
and it's just like oh or you know that's
I'm married to an artist I don't know
how wrong that is man yeah yeah I think
it's pretty bang on but but
um we'll edit that out
they're all a little bit you know as a
wheat I think no but everybody is
everybody's a little [ __ ] up
and so you gotta like or is that just a
story We Tell ourselves no no I I they
are if you really kind of pay attention
to people everybody's got like a
you know a thing that they're doing
you know the person that laughs after
everything that they say at like a party
I mean they're just like wildly insecure
and you know their mother said something
that they're carrying or just something
and I just
you know I just think their gift is they
know how to fix things or design things
or they're in the medical field and all
that I think that yeah like they're just
like
you know
I can tell you like everybody's like
pilots and all Pilots there's something
Pilots all got like a they're a little
[ __ ] nuts
no but then they go up they go up there
safe trip boys no they go up there and
then it makes sense and everything that
and then they they're just like you got
to be like laser focused so all the
[ __ ] in your head quiets
yeah no you want a guy a little nuts or
a woman a little I like a female pilot
too because I feel like okay I'm glad
you got that in there well she went
through extra [ __ ] yeah like she
definitely she had to do an extra triple
Lindy with the [ __ ]
747 to get up there so uh I go the
office route I got a few buddies of mine
just being like God they would have
brought up there
like and because of that [ __ ] mindset
think about what she went through to get
there so
hey KK we're advertising the ideal
product for you hmm will it be book that
explains how anyone who disagrees with
powerful Russian men like me must grovel
at my feet three generations of my
family have been super ultra light Fly
Away skin and bone only boxing champion
uh not really mate advertising manual
which is a men's health company that
specializes in hair loss treatments I
have plenty of her not on your head good
point you destroyed you that it affects
all kitchens I started losing her at 12
which is very late by Russian standards
all you need to do is fill out a free
questionnaire Emmanuel will refer you to
one of their licensed clinicians and
they will then provide you with only
clinically proven medically backed hair
loss treatments based on your needs no
longer will you be doomed to looking
like a malnourished Rush gangster this
is incredible news the treatments are
effective in 9 out of ten men join over
a hundred thousand men who use manual to
treat their hair loss they have an
180 day money back guarantee so it's
risk-free don't suffer in silence get it
sorted I will take manual and soon I
will have beautiful thick men like
Russian pop star Sergey saksamov
I can't believe he made up something
stop the hair loss now Before It's Too
Late by using the code trigger
5010 or clicking the link in the
description for 50 off your first order
and 10 off your second that is trigger
five zero one zero for fifty percent of
first order and ten percent of second
order goodbye
you know a lot of people use stand up as
a springboard to then become an actor to
be able to become a director or whatever
it may be but you've always done stand
up why is that why did you never use it
as a static because you know you could
do well he does other stuff but yeah you
can stand up first right yeah but you've
always gone back to stand up right why
is that
because I love it I mean I just
I can't not do it
um I uh I don't know I I
and I also know I'm not dumb enough
to just give into this business and then
that now I I got now I have a boss the
industry and I gotta you know and I'm
gonna go through hot and cold periods
like anybody else and now I gotta sit
around and I gotta think like oh [ __ ]
you know uh they don't want me to play
the computer guy in the next mission
impossible or something like whatever
the [ __ ] my role would be the redhead
rule
um
you know what I like about stand-up not
only do I love it but it also affords me
the ability to say no to [ __ ] because
and as long as I don't
you know
stop writing jokes and I keep trying to
get better you know and you know you
lose fans along the way all these people
that are upset that I'm happy
evidently I don't know
um but like I can like
you know I know that I can always go out
and every month I can do some jokes
which was the dream
who's never really beyond that other
than the same you know one every you
know I'd like to thank the academy you
know everybody has that one but like the
real thing was if I had to choose
between that
uh and stand up it's it's uh
you know it's a no-brainer like if they
said you could only choose one you can
never do anything else it'd be a
stand-up stand up stand up stand up
stand up all day long all day long
because Eddie Murphy said that was his
big regret was that when everything
happened and that he gave up the stand
up and now he's got to a point where he
feels like he can't go back because the
Legends has built up so much about how
great he was of course he was incredible
we all love Daddy Murphy oh yeah that
guy that guy is arguably the most
talented person in the last half a
century maybe 60 years I'd go back I
mean he's like in the level of like you
know
Michael Jackson James probably just
uh Tony Williams they're gonna throw a
drummer in there
um
yeah but you know if you look at his
specials and just know how young he was
when he did those and like when I love
watching Raw because it was right as he
was really
you know like Delirious is him just
killing in the crowd loving him you know
but when you watch Raw you see him start
you know when he was talking about his
life and being nervous about getting
married and paying Alamo they get half
and some woman I don't know if you got
that she goes that's right he goes no
that's [ __ ] I was just like like
here's this new
like
you know
I just think that
yeah I mean I don't know everybody has
their own way that they do it but like
um
I don't think the Legend's too big I
think that he would come back and
everyone would be totally excited
and you want to hear what he had to say
and it's just
I think more
once he got comfortable that we were
comfortable I I just think
and then that would be it and he would
blow by all of us yeah all of us all of
us quickly I mean you think you're
talking about a guy that can like
I mean
obviously hilarious so he could do the
stand-up thing he can do dead on
Impressions he's got the music ability I
mean just and then he he has that
that that like
star thing like I mean
I you know there hasn't been another one
come along no as bright as that and I
don't think it's even been close maybe
Jamie Foxx
but Jamie Foxx was Never As Good As
stand up as Eddie Murphy he could have
been I think he just kind of came in
like with the acting and all that type
of stuff but Jamie Foxx is another guy
like those guys guys want to see guys
like that I'm like why am I in this
[ __ ] business I actually watched this
thing this clip from uh I never even saw
the movies on Mike Epps movie and he did
this scene where he was asking for like
a lottery
number and he's telling the guy the
number and then he just starts
beatboxing saying the number
15.
30.
37.
38 45 47.
15
30. 37 38.
7
just hurry up I got customers
all right
and just watching that
um like scenes like that like I just
like how the [ __ ] did am I even in this
business when there's a guy that town
like Kat Williams is another guy yeah uh
Sam Rockwell's another guy that makes me
think that
um
well while we're on that subject Bill
excluding yourself greatest five
stand-ups of all time for you
um
it's funny you said excluding yourself
whenever I watch rappers they always go
like someone's me
I thought I'd make it easier for you
just get yourself out of it it's so
[ __ ] funny it's it's like nauseating
the narcissism and then I just there's
something about the honesty of that
well I'm obviously amazing but you know
when Kanye does it you go yeah that's
fair you could that's that's legitimate
to put yourself in the top five and he
definitely would
yeah and there's something about it it's
just it's fun yeah it's fun to listen to
somebody talking [ __ ] about themselves
um
top what do you say top five so yeah at
a time
okay uh prior Carlin
uh Joan Rivers
uh it's more gets hard like who am I
gonna put in like I just love so many
people
um
these are just influential people for me
uh Chong uh
uh you know uh Sam kitterson I'm not
going one more I guess
[Laughter]
um
he's gonna give us the top 50 now yeah I
only don't throw Patrice in there just
because I knew that idiot
and it would bug him it would bug him if
he heard me and if I put him in or if I
didn't but uh you know Mitch Hedberg
Doug Stanhope
uh Joe Rogan
um and that's why I hate doing this Mike
Epps I know I'm gonna forget somebody
it's hard to do people that are doing it
right now yeah you're making me like
look back yeah yeah
um obviously him uh
Jesus Christ me doing that is literally
like when the guy wins the Oscar and he
forgets to thank his wife
he said I forget Dave yeah thanks
[Music]
thank you you know what it was I was
trying so hard to make sure all these
other people that I feel don't get
um the recognition they deserve yeah
well we're on to about 55 at this point
man it's interesting people never say
Kennison I think people have forgotten
Kennison Chris Rock said Kinison was a
lost yeah what about rock what about
rocks
well some of those guys it's like you
don't need to say it because they're
they're like oh
um I gotta throw somebody in there that
uh oh [ __ ] Jim Carrey yeah dude Jim
Carrey being Tony Clifton imitating the
Kennedy reenacting the Kennedy
assassination is one of the greatest
pieces of physical comedy you're ever
gonna [ __ ] watch
[Music]
Johnson County
it's unfucking believable and I got a
chance when I did SNL to talk to him
about it I go did you work that out he
goes no I just he just he just saw the
car and he got in and did it and it's
just like
that's just things just like [ __ ] I
gotta I gotta work hard
yeah
um
so there you go we did it we talked we
talked [ __ ] world politics
right John I know there's other people
George Global I liked
gonna go back to the old school guys
George Goebel uh Rodney Dangerfield oh
my God Rodney come on so good there's
too many of them
uh there you go Bill's favorite five
stand-ups yeah Bill Cosby
I'm glad you brought him up I mean look
Louie CK Louis CK David tell oh
[ __ ] Berlin
um you almost have to be just like you
got to do like all right your favorite
comedians in New York City during this
period because being that it would have
been Chappelle tell Louis C.K
um oh God I'm getting so old I gotta
remember the names here the Greer Barnes
yeah
um Talent favorite British stand up
famous British stand up uh
oh
I saw this guy I'm gonna I don't know
what his name is
I retweeted it he did some [ __ ] up
I can't remember he just did this
completely [ __ ] up bit
it was about a house and an attic and
something that a kid saw it was so
[ __ ] dark I can't even I can't
remember the premise
of it um
loves this ship I can't remember yeah if
we find out really bad yeah what was do
you remember the joke or anything like
that
is there a comic with last name Boyle
Frankie Frankie boys
yeah yeah I can't remember the promises
a bit and I saw it I just was [ __ ]
screaming laughing so I mean I'll be
I'll be honest with you I don't know
enough about the British comedy scene
because I'm all the way over here and
I'd be honest with you I don't watch
Comedy because I don't want other
people's jokes in my head that's
interesting and then like 15 years later
I go to grab for a reference like I'll
tell you what's up [ __ ] blew my mind
the other day
blew my mind I was in a movie
and uh my character
was drinking right and it was like a
comedy whatever so I had some hard stuff
and I just poured a little into the beer
and everybody was thinking that oh my
God that's so funny it was just
something I I thought that I thought to
do
and then you know we've been trying to
figure out the right opening for this
movie so we were trying to find these
movies that had like
that didn't say anything but put you in
the world like you know fat City and
then like uh
uh Manchester said hey you should check
out the beginning of the Bad News Bears
and they just show like you know the
Little League field the sprinkler going
and he pulls up in this old Cadillac and
he has a beer and he takes out a flask
and he poured it in the beer so I saw
that when I was like eight years old and
forgot if I
I mean I don't know if that's why I did
it but that's why I don't watch other
people's
stand up I have this weird thing but if
I see him live
it doesn't stick there's something about
me being home and watching the special
that it becomes more like a permanent
thing where like I just think because
I'm down in the club I'm kind of going
in and out watching a little bit and I'm
thinking about what I'm going to talk
about and stuff that it doesn't sort of
glom on somewhere here but I saw that I
was just like I was like oh I
had no recollection of that whatsoever
so
you know what stand up is a different
beast when it's live like I I like I
love watching like your specials they're
great the latest one included but it's
when it's live that's when it's exciting
do you know what I mean that's when you
get that's when you understand why stand
up is incredible because when you watch
it on screen again it's entertaining you
you'll laugh you'll enjoy it and then
you move on to the next thing but when
you watch it live that's when it turns
into a different beat yeah no it's
amazing it's nothing too where it's not
it doesn't fall off
like it doesn't like you can have like
dips as far as people coming out to the
clubs but it's just it's like music
so people are always going to listen to
music they just you know like styles of
stand up
fall off but like when people say like
you know when do you think this whole
stand-up thing
the boom or whatever is going to end
it's like it isn't because every
generation needs
their
uh their comedians they need their bands
they need all of that stuff so it's not
gonna like uh
I hope not I shouldn't say this Saturday
said Trump wasn't going to be a big deal
[Laughter]
so but I think it's important to people
I remember I was uh opening for a good
friend of mine Jeff norcott His
Brilliant UK comic and my girlfriend is
going for a really hard time and she was
feeling quite down I said to her look
come and watch your show like you've
seen all my [ __ ] a million times but
Jeff's brilliant and she sat and she
watched Jeff's show and when she came
out she was literally it seemed like a
completely different person she was like
that's exactly what I needed I just
needed to sit down laugh my ass off and
it's cathartic no it is that's a bit
those are my favorite you know if I get
like an email or a
a tweet if I actually read it because
I'm bad with both of those but
occasionally I'll get some or some will
come up to you say hey man I was going
through a really bad period in my life
and your comedy helped me and uh it's
weird you almost feel like uh
embarrassed when they say it because
it's just like
oh because I'm doing this for me
I'm selfishly doing this for me and
you're acting like I took time out of my
day
to help you and it makes you just I just
really but I love when people say that
because it gets me out of my own head
going you know if you get frustrated
with the business and it's just like
you know you're lucky enough that you're
funny and that you doing this is
actually helping other people out that
should be enough for you so stop
worrying about this other [ __ ] it's so
in a way I actually get probably more
out of it than saying it than they do
telling it to me bill it's a nice
positive note to finish on we'll ask you
a couple of questions from uh
no no they're making this happen man
let's give them two two questions but
um
[Laughter]
but before we do we'll ask you the
question we ask all our guests which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about that we really should be
isn't everybody talking about everything
at this point what on this episode no no
whatever you want just in general as a
society
I I don't I don't know dude I don't know
I'm sorry that's a deep one what's the
one thing something you think doesn't
get as much attention as it should I
think we covered all of that didn't we
it's just like either uh
the population problem I gotta go to
that again I mean I feel like that's
gonna solve a lot of [ __ ] problems we
talked about that before the podcast
started so give us give us give it give
it to us again what's the population
problem Bill well there's too many
goddamn people that's that's the whole
like all these inventions and all of
this [ __ ] are nice but if there's too
many people around using them so you got
to figure out a way
without becoming a mass murderer to get
people to to die yeah well I did annoys
me when I watched the news and you just
see these weather men go and I'll tell
you it's gonna be a hot one and it's
like how do you not how do you do that
job as a [ __ ] weatherman I feel like
there's two kinds of weathermen the
people who are actually [ __ ] paying
attention to that [ __ ] and then the
other person who just wanted to get on
TV so they have a hot [ __ ] wife you
know what I mean and I see those like
the LA weatherman you got to watch watch
the local news like the [ __ ] La
weatherman they just sit there like you
know you know tonight it's gonna be
cloudy when we get back in these crazy
jackets on it yet I mean I love it
because they're like entertaining but
like it's like dude you look like you're
selling cars and I just think that's
such a funny personality to have
while all of this end of the world [ __ ]
you know Lakes are drying up and all
this just too [ __ ] terrifying to talk
about so
um
well we did have an upbeat one now we've
got a downbeat one but that's your fault
you said it added on a nice positive
note you wanted to keep going
Bill Burr thank you so much for coming
on I really recommend everybody check
out your latest special all right thanks
for having me and I hope I get over
there I gotta go to Wimbledon that's the
last tennis major I haven't been to you
haven't been to Wimbledon no what's
great is you can knock out Wimbledon and
then go down and see the Tour de France
yeah that's one of my thing I just want
to stand there and hand a cup of water
without tipping the guy over and be like
I did it I was that guy fantastic UK man
so come on over all right I'll be there
thank you so much and thank you for
watching and listening we'll see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one oral show all of them go
out at 7 pm UK time and for those of you
who like yourself
do it again sorry no we're gonna keep
that in all right we're gonna keep it in
right keep watching mate we'll have
another silly [ __ ] on next week
couldn't have put it back myself taking
on locals for the bonus questions take
care and we'll see you soon bye
[Music]
yes
oh this is the best answer that question
I've ever [ __ ] heard
[Music]